where Connor was really nice I'm gonna
donate to your YMCA I'm gonna help you
with the hot sauce part of you is like
okay this is new and kind of Novel for
Connor but at the same time as like the
stakes aren't that high for this fight
right and then three of course where
he's going absolutely crazy you know
your wife's in my DS it was a wild time
yeah he had some fun with it I remember
when he was doing that nice guy stuff
I'm gonna donate what do you think that
was about well I like it if he was doing
it to be condescending if he's doing it
like I've got so much money I can even
help you that I'm into the whole thing
you know you got put in the paper for
getting caught you know beating up a
girl and snorting so you're trying to
repair your image it's like man don't be
a punk sometimes just be who you are you
want to be that nice guy but the
audience can tell you're acting you're
being